and then of course met up with a company
you guys hear me support on here and
it's literally it's just organic there's
no I've no I don't own part of the
company and people ask me all the time
with certain brands but the great's
company out of Brooklyn born in Brooklyn
made in Italy met up with those guys
that came to the show and I made a photo
shoot for him afterwards and just good
dudes man and I think it's finally time
it's been such a process the firing the
kid shoes gonna drop the big round great
shoe I just got the sample today and I
wanted to tweet out but they told me I
can't I get the sample today and I
wanted it in like a army green and with
light tan like features on it with the
final kid logos on it it's pretty dope
okay so you're definitely more into
actual
you have you and Brendan vibe on fashion
[ __ ] a lot more than than you and I do
oh yeah yeah the minute he sent me the
picture I thought of so many outfits I
could be wearing with you so you know
originally the shoot was supposed to be
like a tan and red and then when he sent
me the like preview of it I'm like well
unless you play for San 49ers you can't
wear that shoe like I can't and we can't
have that so I want I want the theme
more of like like for the fans aren't
the final kid tribe fine kid army you
know and so that's why it's like an all
like a dark olive like army helmet green
it's pretty sweet Helen podcasting gets
us their own shoe every month we got to
play a little this strengthening of a
song K to play for you cuz this is your
last week and we have a guest on
Wednesday so there's only one there's
one song it's one song lonely it's from
my girl Sarah McLachlan and so I'm gonna
play this I'm gonna play this for him
we're gonna get into you departing this
show and you kind of you start off as
just a young tadpole and you grew some
legs and you went jumped to another
company so here's your here's your theme
song
you ain't gonna cry and I can start
crying
you dine to us
yeah Brendan wasn't kidding you know
you're no longer allowed back on the
premises after one day walking all your
numbers
I mean classic song last time they
played that one they want you to donate
money to those dogs that have been beat
and the cats have been starved for like
six weeks you wanna try some some kids
in Africa's plate for just a small song
that [ __ ] gets me every time
ah kay-kay you're leaving us but this is
the thing is you're leaving to pursue a
bigger dream so it's not sad like we
really should be celebrating I know I
play that slow ass sad ass song Sarah
McLachlan for sure make another Jam
though that's like all she has right she
has like an eighth song called angel
that's really good she's a but that's
that's another sad puppy really she's a
she's a songbird of that's a hundred
percent another donate to starving
children dying dogs or cancer patients
that's her thing but it's actually
pretty cool because it's a you know
because you hear that music they see the
sad face you donate money with you
though obviously I've just messed around
playing that and Sarah McLachlan's the
Angel of Darkness voice but you leaving
it's a positive thing because you're
going on other stuff that you actually
want to do not that you don't love doing
this and you grew the fine kids social
media and you've been a beast with that
and everyone's like dude the volume on
the social media yeah [ __ ] she's not
hooked up the mic it's from herself even
if you had great sound they'd find
something to complain about with the mic
or some [ __ ] like that
anyways but you're going on to pursue
something that you love
it's like best of both worlds yeah I
think well it's not I am happy because
in the long run you know I'm growing and
that's what I wanted to pursue it's just
sad because like I'm used to hanging out
with you guys and for me it's not like I
said before it's not really a job like
I'm coming here and we just all like
dick around and it's just fun but what
about the shipping and the shirts and
stuff that was a little bit of a beast
yeah I don't know I mean it wasn't hard
you know it was like just get it done
that was more of like the job part of it
but it was cool like I enjoyed it your
mom's not gonna miss the boxes of shirt
that I force you oh we got 15 boxes on
the porch you have to bring in I don't
bring that [ __ ] in how'd you get him I
need to send your mom flowers some [ __ ]
for putting up with me not me for sure
because I should get some too if I break
down yeah sure
well to me the biggest fight card of all
time
not even close I think the delay of the
UFC getting authorized and sanctioned in
New York City only made this fight card
even bigger and allowed for a guy like
Connor McGregor to headline it so that
she did the UFC a service by not letting
him for so long cuz there's so much
anticipation hype behind this fight now
let's start let's start with Tim Kennedy
and Rashad Evans and we'll go up from
there the cards ridicu see yeah and you
know the card stack when Frankie Edgar
and Stevens is on the prelims yeah Oh
Habib [ __ ] Murtagh is freaking on the
prelim Dana very alvarez champion Conor
McGregor 145 champion going for that 55
belt
I mean timeout history in the making I
thought long and hard about this because
I know whoever I sided with I'll get
[ __ ] for it but oh you're Conor McGregor
dick credit I just like the guy I like
Nate Diaz
Conor McGregor this isn't the Red Sox
which the Yankees for God's sakes
they're just fighters where do we start
I think Conor McGregor at 55 is is where
he belongs at in this weight class the
matchups are nightmares for him I don't
think if if Conor McGregor's start off
at 55 he's not Conor McGregor he's not
the face of the UFC he's not the biggest
star of the US he's ever had if he
started off at 55 the matchup to tough
the depth pulls so deep he would still
be a start not like not transcending pop
star like he is now
so I think by him going 45 then doing
that weird catch weight at 170 and then
coming back it has allowed him to
leapfrog all the guys just because of
his star power you look and I I've I
know I've told you guys this before you
look at the top five fighters at 155
there's no one who I would give Conor
McGregor the nod on besides probably
Eddie Alvarez and that's a tough matchup
for me this is a coin flip to me this is
a coin flip to me Eddie Alvarez and you
guys know my bias I'm biased towards
Mark Henry train fighters and he Albers
is a march Mark Henry train fighter
Eddie hours represents everything that
UFC fighters should represent he did not
get into it because of the fame because
of the money they call their underground
king he was champion of Bellator he
fought on just the [ __ ] cards for no
money he didn't do this to get famous he
didn't do this to have more than one car
he didn't do this to be on ESPN or Fox
or anything like that he actually loves
the art of fighting and he is a dog he's
one the few guys left who did not get
into this because he can become famous
dirty it is arbitration meeting and
caught one year it's retroactive that
was that test was in July so he's really
looking at like an 8 month suspension
herself still a long time terrible
terrible not as bad as we thought right
and that's in they did find that he was
he wasn't injecting like real steroids
and stuff like that so yeah that is a
long time isn't it for a fighter it
doesn't not too bad because you're
training you're staying injuries
retroactively so it's from the time you
know so it's like July so he'd still be
training I mean if you had that you
that's it sucks for sure yeah cuz he
didn't fight it 200 so it so she's been
off for a long time he's taking a major
pay cut oh yeah oh yeah missing no it's
seven figures yeah I know it's a hip for
sure but in grand scheme of things not
awful you know could be a lot worse that
could be a lot worse he gave him the
three two years three years can be three
years game ender caiman yeah three years
we forget about father and the kid
nation army what is up guys
Brian the kid Callan he is on set right
now actually it was an emergency call so
he's on the Goldbergs
so it's a one-man shop right now one-man
show I think he said all this outlandish
[ __ ] and now he's actually in the White
House he's actually gonna calm down a
little he's still gonna be himself you
can't control Donald Trump but he's
still gonna be himself but he's gonna
chill out on some of those super agro
and outlandish claims and he's gonna
surround himself with a committee
because they were going over what the
President does dude that job are you
kidding me good luck man you think he
has hair shitty now they need to do it
before and after just like they do there
wait four years
the bags under his eyes he didn't look
like a goddamn blood ham he's done his I
mean the the the wear and tear
presidents take man for those fourths
look Obama black don't crack right they
say black don't crack
well become president don't forget like
[ __ ] avocado the 50s aren't coming
back yeah I like that
is it and now for people that don't know
if you don't know you might be
brontosaurus but you were right around
the Simpsons for 15 years oh god no no
how long seven sorry don't like The
Simpsons have kind of predicted this I
made a post as you yeah we did we did
predict it yes yeah I made a post when
he came in right before he came in that
you know just let you guys know in honor
of Dana being on the show the Simpson
predicted this and it shows a picture of
Trump and him going down an elevator and
then sort posts I think I got it from
worldstar that they showed the exact
same thing in real life you have Trump
yeah
elevator with the exact same motion that
the Simpsons yeah we pre animated we
predicted Schwarzenegger would become
the president Trump I actually would
have preferred Schwarzenegger yeah but
ya know it's you know it's how do you
make people's like comedies gonna have a
golden age now like I don't know well
it's how do you make fun well how do you
keep it original though it's the thing
because how many pets the that's the
easy pickings right now its Trump yeah
how many comics are getting here right
now do Trump bits and they do the Trump
impressions and all that stuff yeah you
gotta get creative man for you to stick
out in that world
yeah we have gone from my body my choice
to don't grab my [ __ ] I mean I think
people are losing ground and uh sorry
yeah you you if you put Danish girl and
spider-man together you gotta block it's
literally like either something like
that has to do with you know gays and
with that stuff right or there's it's
action yeah that's super stuff I if I
wrote a show about a bipolar transformin
struggling with her sobriety that
happens to fight crime at night yeah
you're gonna when Tom B's if I just
wrote that I get an Oscar if I added
that she was a monster hunter then
people would actually watch it so it's a
it's all in its own what you do but
these things go in cycles and I you know
there are there are reasons I think that
zombies are very popular now there you
know horror movies and science fiction
movies tend to reflect the times that
they're in meaning well I'll give you a
I'll give you an example
you know Frankenstein when it came out
in the in the early 30s it was very very
popular and it was really a story of
like the the ascent of the Industrial
Age she was Frank as I was made by
machines he was not a human being he was
made by machines and that was a big a
big existential concern at the time was
the the beginning of the Industrial Age
and then in the and then the depression
in world war two people just needed
escapism and that's why during those
years the Wolfman Dracula all those
movies came out because people just
wanted to think about anything
but what was going on outside yeah you
know but the Depression in World War two
life was scary enough they wanted to go
to a weird time and see a mummy or a
Wolfman or just something that took them
out of the the terror of their regular
life sure in the 50s the big fear was
that we were going to get into a nuclear
war with an atomic war with Russia the
Cold War was all about the Cold War
following World War two whether or not
the United States and the Soviet Union
we're gonna obliterate each other with
atomic weapons and all of those that's
when you get all those giant spider
giant bug movies them praying mantis war
the world's it was all about either the
effects of atomic radiation Godzilla
Godzilla or or an alien invasion war the
world's Day the Earth Stood Still earth
first as the flying saucers but those
are all just analogies for communism
which was the big fear at the time in
the 80s you had all of these weird
movies you had a lot of you had a lot of
vampire movies and a lot of werewolf
movies and all these Freddy Krueger
there's all about the fly these are
about a lot of the movies yeah and
here's the interesting about alien you
know an alien the trick of the aliens is
the monster came out of your guts that
you incubated the monster and that was a
quintessentially 80s movie because the
anxiety in the 80s was AIDS and other
diseases and you're you couldn't trust
your own body anymore and the fly is a
great example of an 80s horror movie
that you can no longer trust your own
body and I think now and this goes to
what we were talking about before with
you know people feel like life is cheap
you know with the advent of
globalization you know people their job
doesn't pay what it used to pay
everybody including myself is working
five times as hard for one third the
money and life is cheap and people feel
dehumanized
and what is more evocative of that than
walkers we Trump heavy on basically
every news choice that you could
possibly go with which is a weird one so
I found a couple of the weird ones we
can just consolidate it into one event
bring will go to the other stuff so
first off former KKK Grand Wizard David
Duke
is reassuring all of his white
supremacist voters after Trump's victory
speech that uh that they played a huge
role in getting him elected yes
obviously not maybe not the greatest
look for a president that's a great
endorsement my comment on that is you
know former I think once a Grand Wizard
always a grand no yeah you're you're
always that guy and does he show up at
the other Wizard meetings Gandalf and
Dumbledore like oh please not that guy
to just over him yes seriously yeah once
you're kind of the Grand Wizard of
racism there's no getting out man but I
was trying to figure out why is today so
dark and gloomy today's case last day
for reals Kay I know you were late - by
the way some nerve can't fire you it's
your last day actually you're fired
you can't quit you're fired now I'll hit
you driving home today on the freeway
cuz I won't touch you anymore we're done
just kidding you see have to ship out
those shirts we sold out of a place once
that's over
lose my number once that's over lose my
number the shipping and stuff weird or
the social services I do know hey Gohan
hey come on you're not fired yet you're
you rehired
she didn't say do your laundry no no no
no she has to do my chess device some
reason that's not the 50s I wish